mr. Justin now in this country and you
you know this the name is country we
have an old relationship with red hair
you guys are so mean to your right I was
going to say that I understand it it's
not it doesn't happen well it happens a
little bit United States but you guys
are really mean to you
well one time to me I mean I was working
in Thailand with a bunch of British guys
and they were telling me that everyone
yet you know calls him ginger and makes
fun no that doesn't happen and I was in
the airport in Bangkok and I heard this
in these English guys go change
[Laughter]
didn't your parents kind of prep you for
school any trouble you might have in
school yeah I was an odd kid I mean
actually that photo you showed me as a
child was probably in the 8th it was
definitely the 80s ok and you saw you
know my hairstyle and my crooked tooth
hanging out of my mouth and whenever
people would you know make fun of me I
can call me carrot top whatever I come
home crying and my parents would give me
comebacks you know so then I go to
school the next day and they you know
make fun of me call me carrot top and I
just turn around and I go carrot tops
are green
[Applause]
ciao come on stage on Luke now are you
hanging with Italians now I am and it's
actually it's it's hysterical because
the more time I hang out with someone I
start to take on their characteristics
without really trying and see I just did
it trying I have people come up to me
and go do you have an accent I'm
starting to sound like an Italian which
is not necessarily a bad thing except
sometimes when you talk Jessica you've
got a lovely dog what's your dog called
Chaplin Chaplin
oh there now Chaplin is very special
tell us why he's special well I got him
from a rescue organization he was hit by
a car when he was a puppy so he only has
three legs
and I called name him Chaplin because
when he sits down his takes his leg and
sits like this like Chaplin with this
cave oh the front is it the front leg
yeah so what happens when he wants to do
we keep balances on two legs
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank you view transaction Forbes but in
the debt where you play the young helen
mirren
what was the martial art you were to get
out was Krav Maga
what did Krav Maga where's that from
it's it's the Israeli Defense Army way
of fighting it's super intense it's
basically how you kill your opponent
that's quickly as possible easy busy
people to kill training with someone
from the Israeli Defense Army Wow so did
you get properly good news yeah I was
pretty good I was pretty good look a lot
of fun can you demonstrate could you
like if I could you break a board
can you be like Karate Kid abort yeah
you do could you even got moved yeah
like if someone came at me with a knife
or something or had a gun I could disarm
no okay survived attacked you because a
bit of fruit you like it hurt no
seriously would you hurt me are you a
bit bad at it like will you break my arm
I'll go very slow I'm sick now this is
an amusing idea okay okay do you really
promise I swear
thank you can you trust her you see
totally
[Applause]
if you were gonna stab me would you
really hold a knife like that
no I feel I'm sorry oh wait I'm holding
it wrong
I'll disarm you the minute you start
holding it properly
so like that well no okay fine
sure no I was like oh this this is fine
so base no no wait a minute no how do
you like if you're gonna stab me there
you go perfect
let's do it again okay so I'm coming at
you yeah then I go like this I'm doing
it so much and so I don't hurt you
[Applause]
didn't even bruise the banana and you
are a lover of the Australian wildlife
what's this picture taken in Australia
you with the kangaroo oh that was a New
York King it's a traveling kangaroo yeah
that is a baby kangaroo but what makes
me slightly disappointed is it's totally
upstaging me on that cover advice it is
pretty cool I'm guessing the kangaroo
was quite squirmy
yeah I mean they're very hoppy yeah yeah
and you know likes to play likes to hop
around but was very very happy whenever
I had the bottle because they would do
anything for the bulk I feel you'd had
enough of the hoppy because there's a
picture inside the magazine of you with
the kangaroo and it's just like give me
the food Photoshop the bottle out right
Jessica you wanted a band but you and
your friends did you did sing door to
door yes this is so birdy okay it's cute
okay so - you were like 25 I was like
ten years old duck sees not nerdy it's
cute it's slightly dangerous though
because I was the artistic director of
the cul-de-sac theater like
neighbourhood and to raise money other
kids and I would go door-to-door and
sing a song about cleaning their houses
to Ghostbusters so like the the tune of
ghostbusters but we were called
ourselves the dirt like if your maids on
strike we don't clean that's a psyche
who you gonna call Buster's and then
we'd stand there and just go man
[Music]
and we go into these strangers houses
and clean their house we did terrible
job but it's probably very dangerous it
was a different time Jessica when you've
been on the show before you talk to us
about your grandmother yes
now she's quite um what is a sexually
active she's not sexually active what
maybe she's come out of me that my
grandmother was sexually active and she
she likes she likes men okay your
grandmother has this picture which I
think yes oh this is this is on a
bedside table this is her Al Pacino
yeah you reduce them yes but she's not
sexually active without Pacino no and I
was doing a play with Al it was my first
thing it was in La Salome and my
grandmother was there and she's a huge
fan she loves The Godfather she'd be
freaking out right now and so I said al
I want you to meet my grandmother and he
looked at her and he goes that's your
grandmother hubba-hubba
[Applause]
which of course made her life and so I
took a picture of the two of them and
she framed it and put on her bedside
table didn't you when you got to LA make
it your life's mission to get her a
boyfriend yes which I still haven't done
and it's very upsetting to me so there
are any handsome English men out there
who likes redheads and is not a pervert
or anything here no I keep picky picky I
[Laughter]
made a mass comm account for my
grandmother and I did a photo shoot for
her like we did like I did her make a
tasteful very tasteful and then when the
men would call she'd be like it's
someone from the website like okay and I
give her her hands like but the guys
will call and they'd be like what are
you doing right now
like no grandma call and make a date
can't just be willy-nilly going out
there yeah well tik-tok
[Applause]
in your arsenal of course you lots of
Germans fair words me well my dad's from
Germany what that's my favorite thing
Irina standard whirl of Daniel Bruhl
Jodrell I don't talk me the dirtiest
German stuff but I just love it well
then you know yes it's the best yeah in
a fast language to swear him yeah I've
never seen a guest more keen I thought
she liked dogging but no that's their
favorite it's a good well I like schlump
and you got to take your time Sri Lanka
which means that Hanks is stallion but
my favorite is cumin see here got area
tongs Irvine wait times are iMac line of
diksa tons at Anza which means Dancy
little [ __ ] dance
[Applause]
[Music]
you